all right hi everyone this is part of
our version 13.3 design reviews for
language
and it's about visualization and our
first step is
what
um
we were wanting to update the colors for
the Contour and density plots
um this is your proposed new color
scheme
that is the yes
and then other plots there are just for
reference of you know what everything
else is
but so is Jeremy Davis here
yeah I'm here yep
well I mean I do prefer this somewhat to
this at least for this example
yeah me too
okay
so what about some of these other ones
I don't think anything changing on these
other ones nothing there is changing
right now
yeah probably you know 14 we might do
some more color updates
into that blue red
okay space I mean I I do think that
these colors are not the most wonderful
in the world and by the way we had
another Fiasco with this this stupid
um
uh Dynamic thing of something
rasterizing wrong are you aware of this
I am trying to find out exactly what's
going wrong because
yeah the way it's being described to me
you know I I've seen statements like
you know Cloud can't rasterize Dynamic
graphics
which is not true so then so I'm trying
to find out you know what cloud what
Dynamics yeah okay so ask I mean this
came up
where did this come up did this I have
emailed Michael
who seems to know
where did it come from to You Stephen
because it was very much
disembodied statement with no
information in it
was it part of the chat GPT plugin story
I forgot I think it is I think it is
okay all right fine
okay that was that that's the only
change there being made there I mean you
know
and then we're going to you know make
the curves slightly thicker
yeah
but that's not represented there yet so
okay fine
okay uh
and then the next big thing is you know
the height the interactive highlighting
highlighted plot highlighting
um
okay this is mostly design mostly design
and some
yeah
philosophical questions
okay maybe not philosophical very thick
arrows I hate them
okay
okay just my statement so wait a minute
where can I actually see the thing what
are you showing me here
so these are just all these this is a
gallery of things that we could do
it's in process
okay so if I say plot sine X
this
okay why did it take a moment to come up
I'm not sure
okay so this is what it is right now
right
that's at least got that background
color it's three digits everywhere
and I believe it's padding for the minus
sign on
that y coordinate
but it looks like it's padding for a
minus on the x coordinate as well even
though it doesn't need it it's possible
but that's okay I mean
I think
okay so now let's talk about
the the appearance of the call out
right first of all I think that the the
border is way too thick here
okay
anybody else want to comment on on um
we just want it to be a thin border I
don't see why it can't be arbitrarily
thin really
uh the thickness of the boulder has to
has something to do with the rounding um
areas
sorry wrongly radius if it is too thin
it looks it doesn't look good
uh so it's still around it I mean I
don't know do we need to round it I that
that's not Jeremy Davis or Tim that can
you comment on this please Tim has an
example without rounding that looks good
I don't think we have to have rounding
yeah I think it's better without
rounding that way okay
that contrast the curves
that's a good point as well okay so what
do Tim do you want to share some stuff
what are you going to show here this is
that first one there is this one some
things I did yeah
those are the squared coins these are
ones these are actual
um
things we could do with call out now
okay well I don't like the gray
background I I think the gray
I think the
what do we think about Black versus
other colors for the numbers
well um on that light background the
black shows up really well yeah it
matches the ticks and
we did a test so if you'd say
um plot theme
which one is Weber marketing which one
is dark marketing marketing and it
actually works
which is good but on the other hand
having white text on a dark background
would work there too so
yeah I mean that looks fine yeah
so this is a high opacity I mean this
one could even be
you know
more transparent look I think if it had
thinner borders this this
color would be perfectly reasonable
that background color you know what I'm
saying the really pale
yeah I mean if I say
I think this is pretty decent except for
that
except the thickness except for the fact
that the thing isn't centered top bottom
now what's going to happen if I multiply
this thing by uh
you know 10 to the eight or something
and put it inside that evaluate
just to
why is that four digits why is that
second one four digits 8.259
not sure
well those are looking fine what happens
if I make the x-axis be big as well is
it going to leave it's going to leave
space here
okay let's go to turn to the four
so we're going to cross over
I think was where the crossover is
that's a lot of digits
that's a lot of digits I mean sort of
okay there but but it's you know
the default of the threshold for
scientific form to kick in is 10 to the
6 and 10 to the minus 5.
10 to the 6.5 let's say
that's not that horrifying that
transition
now
how did the thing the the thing end up
so far away from the dot is that the way
you want it
um no that can be improved
okay I'm wondering if that happened when
you moved resize the graphic if there's
right yeah measurement thing right isn't
being you know not in the right
coordinate system I guess right yeah
that's what's happened
okay
let me try something else just for fun
the one thing we looked at this morning
is when you do a log plug because then
you have orders of magnitude
scaling difference
um if it's a scaled scaled thickness I'm
aware okay
I'm just trying to see what happens in
this case
I think that looks great I think it
looks great I think it's a success now
there's something non-responsive about
this
yeah I think it's very good I think this
the way that that magnifying glass thing
works is really nice
I think this is a win
cool so just thin down the border on
that
I think so I mean what the hell are
those things
well okay say plot style goes to
directive thickness 0.05 opacity point
two
directive yeah
oh what
wait a minute what the hell is that
look
you have a bug guys no no no it's the
graphics bug
so what happens is is
you know
depending on the OS
lines with lots of points get chunked
into segments
of you know still multiple points you
know like a thousand points and you do
like a hundred of them at a time yeah
and so that is you know the overlap
between those segments
which don't have line caps that are
right we should set the caps on them so
that
those will go I mean they'll still show
up as a passion what I do do I say line
cap a do cat form round
or join form
I think it's cap form is it cat form
okay
but who does the chunking I mean isn't
that it's a part of the graphics
rendering has nothing to do with the top
level code and why does it why does it
change when I move out I think it's
switching you know I think
when your when you Mouse over the curve
it brings up that you know call outs and
I think that's probably switching it to
the 3D renderer for some reason okay
guys you got a bug fine track it down
okay
I'm not I'm not I'm not buying that this
thing here is something to do with the
computer
it's a bug of some kind
all right let's let's come back to what
we're talking about before
okay
so
again significant digits question I mean
I didn't think it was that horrible what
we've got here
um
yeah I mean
Jeremy Tim anybody else
do you want to comment on
I mean I think this opacity could go
just a teeny bit lighter
Maybe
the background opacity here
it's just a lightness though right
there's no I don't think there's opacity
right the question is whether it should
be should it be well no worries we
shouldn't have much of any yeah on dark
Roger it would get muddy
like in your marketing okay yeah so so
then what I'm saying is lighting it the
tiny tiny bit more maybe okay because
we've been successfully using scrims
which are these transparent backgrounds
well is that what this is no it's not no
it's not no there's no opacity here
okay I mean nobody wants opacity
everybody wants transparency
with that
was that a dry joke or is that something
different
yeah but I don't think we need it here I
think we can do without it actually I
think it's okay
um the scrims they they are really
useful when you're when you have very
little screen real estate so then if you
have a call out or a tooltip or
something like that
yeah but by the way is this correct
covers up so much of your screen real
estate Alexis is slicing this this call
out that doesn't seem right
oh
that is annoying for sure
um
and
that's rendering order isn't it
yeah we don't have a lot of control over
that at the moment okay all right fine
it's a bug I find those
um
let's talk about significant digits here
for a minute please
right I mean I think I think you know
the main requirement I have for
significant digits is that you know if I
move up or down or left or right place
why is this jumping I'm moving just a
teeny bit and it's jumping it's picking
the points it's not interpolation it's
not infinitely smooth
if you say
um
uh magicals to all if you see magicals
to all you'll see that those are in fact
the sample points
Roger does that change on image size do
you get more points on like a giant
image size no no no okay it's it's
rendered at the time when the plot comes
through and renders it right right the
highlighting has a granularity
okay you know Sandra was commenting on a
live stream you know does it snap to
maximum Minima and zeros and crossings
and so on given that it's snapping at
all it might as well snap to those
things it doesn't know
but
this is what we want to do in the future
that why does wait a minute just lost it
lost lost it it didn't it didn't come in
immediately to being able to do this
what's going on there
I didn't quite see it or I mean well it
just didn't it wasn't it was inactive I
mean it didn't I I I I changed Focus
okay I come back over here
this
notebook I guess is not in Focus so now
it doesn't focus and not came back okay
fine
okay so in the future there will be a
snap to the zeros and um uh and Maxwell
and things is that right we can do that
but but part of what we had planned was
to be able to
you you might want to highlight zeros
highlight maximum Minima
and we could do this snapping thing we
actually have that in system modeler
um I think we should do the snapping
thing anyway because I think that's
useful to be able to just you know as
you move through here to be able to snap
to those things because that's something
you're going to want to do and it's a
it's a you know it's a harmless thing to
do so to speak yeah
okay
all right is there anything else we need
to okay again I want to talk about these
little thought bubbly things you know
that the way that this
the way this
hoax well I know what you call it the
stalk what do you call it the stalk as
in stalk s-t-a-l-k stork
um right yeah
the pointer
yes okay so Jeremy Davis what do you
think of this thing
I think it's fine I think it's good I
prefer it to the lines like sometimes I
I do too now yeah I do too
all right
maybe we ready to declare Victory here
and you didn't comment on the fact that
we don't have any
parentheses or
you know braces around the numbers
you know it's just
because it's the right thing to not have
any parentheses or braces around the
numbers
I thought we talked about that last time
didn't we did we I don't remember yeah
yeah I think we did
right I mean look the significant digits
thing
seems a bit wrong
but I mean I think you want just enough
digits so that you're guaranteed that
when you move up or down a little bit or
left or right the numbers should change
yeah
we might catch more cases we caught one
this morning which you know when you're
in a log plot when you look up over many
decades
that that you know having exponential
notation is really really nice right
right so we wanna live stream is
commenting about changing public numbers
to the curve color we are changing the
curve color that's what this is doing
um can you send out when you have a
thinner
thing can you send that out to um
and and maybe non-rounded can you send
out some screenshots please sure
what happens when you have like a linear
color function
so I don't think it does it right now
but my thought is you know if it's like
if you have a plot with a color function
it will
you know just use Gray
yeah okay let's take a look at that
let's just take a look at that and right
now it's using the default blue but
or I mean there's three curves using the
three colors no it's using so it's using
the color the defaults
right it's still using the plot style
colors even though you can't see you
know that reflected in the Curve
not the worst thing in the world
it still gives you some identification
purposes I guess yeah I don't think it's
the worst thing in the world to do that
I mean you know it might be considered a
full through case but you know to to
Rainbow it
as you go through this seems crazy right
right I I I was gonna you know use like
a dark gray and go monochrome
um I think what it's doing right now is
actually okay I mean it's a weird Corner
case but I think it's okay
Roger no I agree with you I it's it's
it's decent it's pretty nice right I
mean worst case is that's just the color
of the tool tip if there's only one
curve if the multiple curves you get to
see the difference
um now I mean if I were to
but obviously if I say
um plot style Arrow
red green blue
what the heck is that
I mean I know I asked for one more than
I gave that's can you somebody make a
note of that please
okay
okay I'm just what sense
oh I'm just laughing at the white
yeah well I'm here down to see what
happens yep
right
okay I think Wayne can classify the
white as Geiger right
is
yeah
I mean but if he gets over the whites
you know the coordinates I think will
show up
yeah I think so too there we go oh my
God
okay okay
so a comment here
I think and we can see that also on the
yellow
although I mean the yellow is a bit
Goofy
I guess it's okay I'm I'm wondering
whether there should be some Darkness
added to the outer border
to deal with a case like that because I
mean I think that's too you know that
honestly is too red in the outside
you see what I'm saying and I'm thinking
maybe we could Gray
the outside a little bit to deal with
both of these cases both it might help
when we make it thinner
yeah it might help I might Winston
enough I've just greatness I mean the
white case you can't improve without I
think making the dark case like
marketing worse
okay
I wouldn't worry about this case this is
a stupid case I mean on the other hand
you know you created a pure red curve
when we all know that you don't really
like pure red
yeah I know but that's okay what it did
in the pure red case is okay
um can I try let me just try one more
thing
uh
oh it's all right so
Thomas
yeah
uh it's a question on Livestream does
this work with complex plot as well
let's look at it there
nothing in a complex plot yet it would
probably work with curve plots before we
re-implot would work yeah
okay
is it already hooked up or no
it worked automatically
that's Magic
sword okay
so the the dotted lines
it's just doing the same thing okay it's
going to look much better when this when
the when the um
uh
you know when the when the borders are
thinner I think
I know I'm asking for a lot but why is
there a Gap there
that's a it's it's a discontinuity
no it's not
uh yes it is if you look at it
yeah it's a branch cuff
to say exclusion's none then it won't
compute any of those
no but wait a minute doesn't this go to
pi over 2
at
at one but there is a little
we can't we don't there's no you know
their their potential discontinuities
are all the things that we can detect
yeah okay fine
right if things cancel out or turn out
to be continuous
I've never seen this plot before if you
don't have this as an example in um both
Arc style and reimplot you should
because it's a nice picture don't you
think
um
yes I mean there's probably something
like that in Earth sign at least yeah I
just think it's a nice picture
um
okay what else should we look at here um
go ahead uh I was gonna say I think the
other thing that you know we should
discuss is
the backward compatibility issue
um yes
um did I already see that I mean you
sent me an email about it over the
weekend I think or
the other evening or something okay wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
what's going on here well the messages
from your you know the Primus hero is
not good
zero Prime yeah
three messages though but
because it returned unevaluated and then
something else tried to do something
with it was like oh I'll evaluate again
why is there a big space before the 17
doesn't it know that there are no
negative values
um we'll look into that it may just be
always leaving the space for a minus
sign no we can toggle that yeah right
okay backward compatibility
right so
we have two ways
implemented at the moment of you know
sort of doing these I mean they're very
closely related but you know in terms of
boxes they're different okay
um let me just give a boundary Condition
it's got to be Backward Compatible
period of the story
well I mean you can't always do that
that means we couldn't ever introduce
new things no I understand that if you
take a plot no notebook can fail to
render
that's the constraint
okay
so long as a notebook generated in
version 13 3 renders in previous
versions it's all good
previous versions how far back
eleven
okay
um you know so if you generate one of
these things in 13 3
you open in V12
you will get a dynamic warning
but once you okay the dynamic it will
display your plot without any of the
interactive stuff
I can make that work
okay
we have the dynamic warning but that's
because we had stupid Dynamic warnings
going back in these previous versions
yep
and so disappointing but so Stephen so
what we're doing then is that we are
going to do packlet updates to these
older versions
uh for some things
uh but we can't yet but we would like to
switch eventually in to use a newer
technology called template box but that
didn't exist in previous version it
cannot be updated because it's
front end code I mean and to be clear
template boxes existed for a while but
it's only in 13 3 that it has started
working in graphics box
yeah and so at some point in the future
gonna be a while
it's gonna be a while
yeah okay I mean five years type while
right so we until then we're going to
generate a lot more code you know into
graphics
what do you mean a lot more code because
we have to deal with previous versions
no no I mean because throwing bits of
meta information so that we can do the
highlighting
as opposed to what as opposed to using a
template box which is kind of very
you know minimalistic right well
obviously any new function that you
introduce
you can use the No actually that's not
right because a notebook has to be
renderable
I I think this is not the conversation
here we should talk to John fultz about
what possibilities exist he may have
some better idea I mean if the thing
ends up having something that says you
know you need to upgrade or something
that will be okay
but having it splatter all over the
place is not okay
splatter it's not going to render right
now but I have I just had another idea
Brett which is
that just as we update
the update we're talking about now that
we back propagate
right what about
if we provided a tool that can recognize
these graphics and say would you like to
convert it at some point in the future
when we do switch to to cleaner and more
efficient you know Graphics code
we don't need to do it now we can
generate the thing that's just gonna
work
mm-hmm but you see what I'm saying
because at some point gonna cut the cord
right and then means it's not renderable
in in
the older ones unless we have some kind
of conversion tool there
well I mean the other possibility
look we we've we've dealt with this kind
of issue before
the lack of a time machine is very
annoying
okay let's think about this for a second
really I mean I know that Lou Will
frequently put something in place you
know like in 13-3 with the idea that 14
will use it
yeah
um
which is sort of the path we're on now
but if Stephen says five years then then
you know
well let's just think about it for a
second I mean the issue is this somebody
sends somebody a notebook
and it's a question of what exactly it
does
you see what I'm saying because it's
gonna say this notebook was produced in
a more recent version of the product
now we've talked about recently removing
that message but we should now pull back
on removing that message
if you do it with you know well I guess
that's the other way
you know I was thinking of the thing
where like if you were to open a V6
notebook in your
you know the thing you're running right
now oh no no then it gives you a bunch
of nice messaging and that's all good
yep just offers you to upgrade some
stuff
um but that's easy that's that's not a
time machine
um
look you're gonna already have a warning
saying this was produced in a more
recent version
I think you have to look in detail at
what it does okay
in previous versions because it might be
okay I mean it might be it's in a more
recent version Oh something doesn't
render
I mean it might also be the case that
it's worth us putting something in
let's see
you see again you've got to have Lou and
John and so on here I don't know if we
can yeah no I mean but Brett we should
go down this path of thinking about sort
of
uh because at some point we're going to
want just to cut the chord so to speak
but then if we have an actual
conversion routine deployed for the
older versions then they have a chance
yeah but but also here's another point
there may be some trickery which will
allow us when it doesn't render
you know with the template box and so on
there may be some you know hook that
already existed in templates boxes from
version six or something that we could
plug into
see what I'm saying
nobody in this meeting knows that right
this is a piece of archeology
right but there might be some
you know alternate Graphics rendering
mode thingy that we can generate which
will be utterly useless in version 13 3
will do nothing
but in the case where it was a you know
a desperation rendering thing in version
six point whatever it will do something
so I mean that's a I don't know do can
somebody try to get John and Lou here
for a minute to see if they're available
just ask them
John Forbes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes
grabbing him
well he may not be available but let's
find out please
um
um I'll be us on live stream loss how
about changing the arrow cluster into a
Crosshair when hovering over the curves
graph
ing curse oh the the I see I see the the
the
um the pointer Arrow oh
it's an interesting thought I don't
think we modify the the um the cursor
again that's a front-end story
do we modify the cursor when we go into
a graph that's an interesting idea we do
we really do it in 3D yeah and we do for
graphs you know graphis and graph Theory
you know we do we do modify the cursor
in many cases
well I'm seeing something
I'm seeing an arrow there a little
Double Arrow there what the heck is that
about it's got an arrow with like an
edge at the bottom base of it
yeah it's got It's got the
yeah what does that show
s that you're in a graph not a graphic
it's only when it's over the vertices or
does it do with the edges also well that
does it for the edges okay I see John
has joined okay
um we have a question
okay
these guys would like to use a modern
Graphics box template box construction
to do this highlighting business
Johnny with us yeah
and the issue is what happens when that
template box is fed to an earlier
version of the front end
um
so if there's no explicit display
function then uh
then it'll pink box
um and
um what do you mean if there's no
explosive what could they do John
template box supporting Graphics box is
new in thirteen three oh oh oh oh okay
okay then
um
then probably the whole graphic with
pink box
okay is there anything they could
include in the graphic that could be
caused not to render in 13 3 and beyond
that would render successfully or at
least limp in earlier versions
and further question we have been
discussing taking out the this is a new
version you know this this was creating
a new version we obviously shouldn't do
that given this development
remember that with discussion we had
yeah
um
the uh
no I mean one of the things to
understand is
old version will not corrupt The
Notebook
so it will not be the case that like if
you open in the old version then you
save it it doesn't yeah well that's good
but but I just want to ask to clarify
this point we had talked about removing
the new version warning we should not do
that
I think it's a more complex issue than
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no nothing that we're looking at
right now no no John I'm just saying we
had talked about within the last few
weeks yes the annoyance of the fact that
we're seeing I'm not saying that solves
this problem in the slightest bit
okay I'm just saying we were not
thinking straight about why to put that
why to keep having that we didn't
actually make a decision it was it was
an agenda item that we never got to so
we didn't actually make a decision all
right fine but I'm saying I'm saying if
we okay I'm glad we didn't make a
decision we should leave it as it is
right now
well nothing is changing until we have a
proper talk about it I'm just okay
that's fine I'm just claiming that this
also does not constitute a proper talk
no that's fine okay we can talk about
you know richening that that dialogue
okay question
is there anything these guys could do
that they can write in thirteen three
that allows them to have a Fighting
Chance
crazy stuff
uh like like a dynamic version that you
know a dynamic box that includes a
legacy version and a new version side by
side and selects based on a version
check
that's absolutely possible it's not
difficult to do it potentially
constitutes crazy
uh
yeah well okay so what are you guys
planning you said you had a plan what is
your plan so basically what we are doing
right now is not using the template box
and we are generating
the normal Primitives and then we have
you know dynamic stuff that implements
the highlighting
I hate it I hate it that Dynamic stuff
is going to be another horrible mess so
so I have two I have two more things to
say about the general issue I don't know
anything about this specific issue but
uh first of all uh this isn't the first
time we've come across this sort of
thing
and our general Mo uh which you know is
a bit painful when you want to get
something out now now but our general MO
is to get the template box definition uh
in uh one version the head of the
version that actually generates the
template box
and depending on you know how often
people might come across it maybe even
more than one version
um well people will come across this in
every single graphic that that that's
what we did for the type setting of
colors for example
um
uh but uh and then the other thing to
say not relevant for 13-3 unfortunately
or 13-2 uh but is it's definitely on our
roadmap to have a uh packlet updatable
way to ship uh uh isolated templates
without having to right now the fact
that they're in core.mb uh causes some
difficulties with packlet updating it
basically means we would have to packlet
update every style sheet we ship
um
uh for reasons
um and uh but we're not unaware that
this is a problem and and the the goal
I'm hoping in 14 uh is that we can have
a library of templates that a doesn't
need to be bound to a style sheet and B
can be incrementally added to uh by
packlet
but just so you know we're thinking
about it okay
so what you're suggesting is
these guys would introduce the template
box definition in 13-3 for 13 3 they
would use Dynamics to get this
highlighting stuff yeah and basically if
he knows it boxes yeah
and then for 14-0 you're suggesting that
they could cut the cord yes or 15 or
well no but let's agree let's understand
what we're actually talking about
because if at 14-0 we do that that means
everybody with 13 2 and Below will get
pink boxes for their Graphics from a
um a notebook from the future correct
and we and we've done this sort of thing
before
and we haven't had a lot of pitchforks
no
I mean probably the most notable one is
hyperlinks
hyperlinks used to be explicit boxes now
they're template boxes we knew that
hyperlinks would be a big deal so I
think I think we set two or three
versions on that one
okay
well fine but now with the Dynamics
that means that
are we going to get stupid I mean we're
dealing with the trust stuff correctly
for this right we're not going to get
warnings in 13-3 but in the previous
ones
right
but we will get warnings because the
previous versions didn't have
self-trusting is that correct because
the previous ones won't know about the
new code that we want to declare as
trusted in 13 3. all right well that's
life I mean I don't see we can avoid
that
with Dynamics
the stuff will work in previous versions
this sounds okay to me and you know to
be clear you know when I say it works I
mean
it you will see
you know if you do a plot you will see
the plot you know if you Mouse over the
plot nothing's going to happen that's
okay yep you can't you can't have
features from the future in the past
right
exactly I mean that's not surprising
that doesn't work right
um
okay
sounds good anything else we need to
discuss here
uh I think that covers everything
sounds good all right okay come
um okay for people who are following our
live streams we are about to start
another one about
elegant code formatting
so yeah and I'll not be totally prepared
because you called me while I Was
preparing for it sorry about that okay
sorry John see you guys okay bye